first question comes from Robert he
wrote a kind of a long question but I've
written my first advertisement which has
been published which will be publishing
two weeks and delivered to my private
houses and the 30-mile radius from his
business I have a new email account and
I dedicate to the new business I'm
expecting the advertisement to get me
some emails with which your help and
advice I might cultivate into an email
list so I'm starting from zero how do we
become an email here oh please easy
Robert it sounds like you got a very
very focused initiative and objective
and if it's a matter of getting started
with those names I would probably start
with creating content that's very
specific to those folks or those that
you're trying to target within that
radius a way to grow your list is to
provide educational content relevant to
what you stand for or what your business
represents so if it's things to do in
the area or if it's just you know quick
tips on historical things about that
area it sounds like it may be a real
estate angle real estate company but if
you if you create that content to be put
into your emails just by the fact that
you're serving that relevant information
to here trying to target even if it's
only five people that will help to grow
that list just by the sheer nature that
you're providing relevant information I
love it what's interesting about this is
he's using kind of traditional ways of
advertising most people think of
building email is from a website not
from doing a direct mail campaign I
would make sure that on your direct mail
piece or your advertisement piece
there's some incentive to want to sign
up for the newsletter you're giving away
some kind of free bonus I'm sure we'll
talk about this later on we can the
strategies but give them a reason to
want to sign up and then like Eric
talked about giving them value in the
newsletter so if you're creating an
autoresponder sequence or you're
creating specialized broadcaster people
you want to build that relationship with
them first to sell himself as an expert
first and then once they know you like
you trust you then much more likely to
want to do business with you and using
that direct mail piece in that
traditional advertising you have a lot
of real estate there to explain the
value and to you know communicate what
someone will get by going to a specific
URL to sign up or even in some cases you
can set up text to join mailing list
where you can just you know people still
use text and you know connecting that
offline to online environment it's a
very valuable way to get folks on your
list and part of growing your audience I
did not know you could do text to join
there you go I've learned something new
in the first five minutes of the session
already I love it